china's army of snow guns is paving the
way for a smooth winter olympics
[Music]
it's the first games to rely entirely on
fake snow and beijing isn't the first
host city to make fresh powder others
have done it too supplementing real snow
on mountain tracks for the world's best
skiers and snowboarders
for producing artificial snow
they require huge amounts of water it's
nearly 2 million
cubic meters of water
that would be enough to fill about 800
olympic sized swimming pools and trying
to access that amount in a water-scarce
city isn't the only feat snow makers
also have to battle the elements
this isn't just a challenge for china
because as the world gets warmer
other host cities may not be cold enough
and end up using more artificial snow
too
we take a look at the logistics and
environmental impact behind china's snow
making process to see what it means for
the future of the world's biggest
sporting event
the first hurdle china needs to clear
make sure there's enough water to make
snow the games are divided into three
zones that are in an area with low
precipitation during winter and not
ideal for creating alpine conditions
because it's one of the driest region of
china that's already suffering from
severe water stress carmen de young is a
geographer who's been studying
artificial snow's environmental impact
not just at the olympics but also ski
resorts and indoor sporting venues so
there's not enough water available
locally it has to be transported from
very far away daeng says one of the
zones sources water from a reservoir 18
miles away and supplies nearby farms and
residents and some parts of that route
are on an incline they've had to build
pumping stations to pump the water
uphill to reach all the snow guns and
snow cannons so all the
olympic ski runs
have pipelines running underground to
supply them with water and electricity
in order to manufacture
the snow this is an energy intensive
process according to sport ecologist
madeleine orr who wrote a report about
the impact of climate change on the
winter olympics
take for example covering one track from
top to bottom the amount of snow guns
that would be needed to produce the snow
for that for a day
is roughly equivalent to like an
apartment small prime filling yeah this
entire process requires close
supervision and china has created its
own snowmaking team
since 2017 these scientists have been
developing artificial snow that would be
suitable for the region the soil is so
dry that the artificial snow doesn't
stick to the ground there's also the
problem of a lot of evaporation
dey young says a way around this issue
is injecting water into the soil
creating a frozen layer optimal for fake
snow to then stick
the region is also prone to strong winds
which doesn't help when it comes time to
spray the area
you know
what
[Music]
as much as beijing or any future host
city may want to control the weather
sport ecologist madeline orr says
there's no amount of artificial snow
that can make up for the lack of cold
the problem is there is no perfect
sustainability when you're producing a
winter event in a summer destination and
so no matter what you do to be more
energy efficient the design of the event
is unsustainable
the beijing organizing committee says
artificial snow making has minimal
impact on the local water supply because
it uses a water conservation system
the international olympic committee said
it's treating climate change as a
serious challenge and that artificial
snow production should be sustainable it
said host regions must have sufficiently
cold temperatures and will be required
to be climate positive
or says the best option may be to not
choose a future location like beijing
it's okay to supplement with artificial
snow some athletes like that it's extra
speedy but it can't be a hundred percent
again
[Music]